This is my ship still I'm in charge. I know I know of course you are.
of course. See you say of course but then
you touch the map it makes you think
that maybe you didn't realize I was in
charge ah, Quill. That's your own insecurities
in there okay I'm merely trying to be of service with the system
quill that's what I said. you should
fight one another for the honor of
leadership it sounds fair. it's not necessary. it's not. okay. I got some
blasters unless you guys want to use
knives. oh yes please use knives no no
there will be no knifing one another,
everybody knows who's in charge
me yes...of course.
welcome back everyone it's Charlie Happy New Year this is going to be
my video all about Thor for love and
thunder and Christian Bale apparently
he's up for a role in the film if you could ever believe it he's coming to the
Marvel Universe so we'll break it down
if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
we're also doing a movie ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and let me know in the video
who you want Christian Bale to play in
Thor for if you remember a couple years
ago Christian Bale has been asked a lot
after he did the Dark Knight trilogy and
played Batman whether or not he would do more Batman or more superhero movies if
he'd ever be in a Marvel movie because
by the time he finished Dark Knight
Rises the Marvel Cinematic Universe had
really started to take off it was still
phase one early phase two days so they
didn't have quite the clout and they
weren't quite as big as they are today
and even as recently as 2017 Christian
Bale had said he had no interest in
working with Marvel on a superhero movie
in the only real superhero movies that
he'd ever watched his entire life were
the Christopher Reeve Superman films and his Batman Dark Knight films so
everyone's wondering what just happened
to change that in which character he
would be playing so what probably
happened is as Taika offered him a
one-off role like Cate Blanchet coming in to do
hella during thor ragnarok you could say
that she could come back because
technically she's the goddess of death
and can you really kill the goddess of
death technically no but they wrote that
role for Cate Blanchet so that she
wouldn't have to come back she only
signed a contract for that one movie so
that's why they killed her off at the
end of the movie in the way that they
did so that was kind of ambiguous you
could say that she's dead and if she
never came back she would just stay dead but if she suddenly wanted to be in
another Marvel movie again they would
totally find a place to put her and just
say no she didn't die so that's the
trick that they used to get big
Hollywood actors on board who wouldn't
necessarily want to sign on for a four
or five picture deal like a standard
actor would when they're becoming an MCU
character the other way they convinced
them to do movies like this is if they
have friends that are also making the
movie either the directors their
personal friend or their friends with the start like that's how Chris
Hemsworth got Matt Damon during Thor
Ragnarok in that funny play you may have
seen that funny home video that Chris
Hemsworth posted of him and Matt Damon
just shooting arrows at each other
playing around their friends in real
life their families go on vacations together so when they were making Thor
Ragnarok he was like hey do you want to
come play this fake version of Loki and
just have fun for a little while no big
commitment it just for this one movie
remember how Ryan Reynolds got Brad Pitt to be in Deadpool to as the Vanisher
character it was a hilarious cameo and
he was only on screen for a brief period
the reason why Brad Pitt did that is
because his kids are big fans of the
Deadpool franchise not because he cares
or he was potentially going to earn a
bunch of money he just did it as a favor
to Ryan Reynolds because his kids were
big fans so odds are no matter who
Christian Bale would be playing it's
probably just going to be for this one film
because I do think that he still kind of
has a lot of disdain for big superhero
franchises and he doesn't want to sign
on for some huge commitment that's why I don't think the character he's up for is
beta ray bill because I think they intend to use beta ray bill in all kinds
of different space-based movies like
guardians of the galaxy would be a great
franchise to put him in even if they
don't do more Guardians films after
Guardians 3 you still have a Guardians
team flying around out there they just
pop up in cameo every once in a while
and you cycle the roster beta ray bill
was even a member of the guardians of
the galaxy recently in the comics the
character I think it makes more sense
for Christian Bale to be playing if he's
going to be playing say like a villain
character would be Dario Agger the CEO
of Roxxon, the Minotaur of for those of you that haven't read the
Thor comics he was one of the first big
villains that Jane Foster Thor faced
when they did the female Thor in the
comics a few years ago they have a lot
of characters in the movie who are
either from earth or on planet earth
after the events of Avengers endgame in
new Asgard is still on earth up in
coastal Norway so it makes sense that
the main villain of the movie or one of
the villains at least would also come
from Earth and because it's a Thor movie
you typically do new characters that
flow from that type of mythology so the
Minotaur of Roxon would be a great
character to introduce he would look
like Christian Bale for most of the
movie because Dario agar walks around
looking like a normal human but then
during the big final battle with Thor
and Jane Foster female Thor he goes into
his full Minotaur form and it becomes
more of a motion-capture fight like when
Mark Ruffalo is doing the Hulk or when
Taika is playing Korg and if you weren't
sure obviously Korg and meek are going to
come back for Thor for they still need
to get their revenge on noobmaster
speaking of new master everybody's been
making Deadpool jokes wouldn't it be
funny if Deadpool in the MCU eventually
when they introduced Ted pull into the
MCU Wayne's up secretly being noob
masters so they weave him into the
history of the MCU in a really clever
way how angry do you think that everyone
would be if Christian Bale is just up
for the new master role and he's only in
it for a one-off joke for like two
seconds
but Roxon is a company that's shown up
all over the Marvel Universe in the MCU
and the TV shows in present-day and
going back to the 1940s during the
events of the agent Carter TV series
they're big oil and gas company they're
known for exploiting the earth's
resources in there a lot of films right
now the big franchise films that are
trading on themes of climate change like
James Cameron's Avatar sequels and it
just makes sense that they would do
something like that with these Thor
characters if all the pieces line up
there were a lot of you that were asking
me if he's playing Gor the god butcher
the reason why I don't think that he's
playing Gore is because they kind of
already gave most of the aspects of that
character to the Helicarrier during
Thor Ragnarok and Gore as a character isn't really integral to the female Jane
Foster Thor origin story and that's
supposed to be a big part of the film so
just explain the basic plot outline that
Taika gave us back at comic-con this is
basically what's going on with Thor for
love and thunder they're doing the Jane
Foster female Thor origin story from the
comics
it'll be a little bit different from the
comic book version but they did say that
they might do the cancer plot they're
still kind of deciding on that because
they're not going to be shooting the movie
for a little while the biggest changes
they're making to that or that that
story happened the reason why Jane
Foster became Thor is because Thor
became unworthy during a big comic book
event the hammer passed to Jane Foster
in Thor didn't wield any hammer for a
long time in the comic eventually he did
get it back he got a shiny gold arm with
a gold hammer and Jane Foster became the new version of Valkyrie but MC youth or
after Avengers endgame is still worthy
he's still wildung Stormbreaker and they
destroyed Mjolnir during Thor Ragnarok
so there are a lot of things that they
had to set up at the beginning of the
film like what hammer is Jane Foster
Thor going to wield the only options for
that are bringing one from the
multiverse if you're talking about Loki
from Avengers and game the one that
escaped with the tesseract creating that
alternate timeline we'll see him again
during the Loki series and maybe during
Doctor Strange 2 they also had to follow
up with Valkyrie being the new queen of
Asgard in what they're going to do with
Asgard going forward because Thor 4 is
being released a couple years after the
end of Avengers endgame I'm assuming
that a couple years will have gone by so
Valkyrie will have been queen of Asgard
for a little while and Thor will have
lost most of his weight on the Bowflex
that he borrowed from star-lord
initially their plans for guardians 3
were a little bit different in terms of
the timing so I think there was going to be
a Thor follow-up scene that would set
him up for Thor for love and thunder
before they changed the release date for
guardians 3 now that's all kind of up in
the air so they'll had to have some sort
of scene to follow up and explain what
happened with Thor in the as guardians
of the galaxy while he was out with them
but then the big question is is what
happens to Chris Hemsworth's Thor going
forward is he returning during Avengers
5 maybe he also gets a cameo when they
eventually introduced Galactus and
Silver Surfer because he spent a lot of
time in the comics crossing over with
those two characters in speaking of
Galactus if you're really hyped up about
him entering the MCU they just did a
Thor story they rebooted the character a
new rider came on the title Galactus
crossed over I won't spoil the story but
it's crazy but because there's a lot of
confusion about what's going on with
female Thor Jane Foster the idea is is
that Thor in the MCU is not unworthy
will not become unworthy so the why she winds up picking up the hammer
is going to be a little bit different from
the comics I think there are a lot of
people that are just confused about how
this is going to work because of the way
it went down in the comics so if you
never read the female Thor comic book
don't worry you won't have to read that
to understand what's going on at the
beginning of Thor for if they give us any more details about what's going on
with the movie or they confirm any more
castings and characters and people
coming back I'll totally include it one
of my Marvel videos but everyone let me
know in the comments if you have any
special requests for future Marvel
videos and every one click here for my
Marvel New Mutants trailer video which
is actually a real movie that's coming
out in theaters believe it or not and
click here for my brand-new Doctor Strange 2 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome Happy
New Year!